There are three mechanisms in SPIN to create protection
domains, and use them. The first one is, of course, the create
call that allows creating a logical protection domain. And
this mechanism in SPIN allows initiating an object
file with the contents and export the names that are contained as
entry point methods inside the object to be visible outside. That's what this
create call, supported by SPIN, provides to a service creator. For example, if
I'm creating a memory management service. I can write the entry point functions
in my memory management service and export the names using this create mechanism
that's available in SPIN. The second mechanism in SPIN is resolving names.
If one protection domain wants to use the names that is there in another
protection domain. The way we can accomplish that is by using this resolve
primitive that's available in SPIN. Resolve is
very similar to linking two separately compiled
files together that a compiler does routinely.
So, you may be very familiar with the
compilation process where you may separately compile
files and once you have done the separate
compilation of the files, then you go through a link phase of the compiler where
the linker resolves the names that are being
used by one object file with the names
that are defined in another object file. That's
the same thing that the resolve mechanism of
SPIN does is, it resolves the names that are being used in source, which is a
logical protection domain, and the target, which is
another logical protection domain. As the result of
this resolve step, the source logical protection domain
and the target logical prediction domain are dynamically
linked or bound together. And once bound
together, accessing methods that are inside this
target protection domain happens at memory speeds,
meaning it is as efficient as a
procedure call, once this resolve step has
happened. As I mention before, to reduce
the proliferation of small logical protection domains
you may want to combine protection domains
to create an aggregate larger protection domain
and SPIN provides a mechanism for that,
which is the combined mechanism. Once the
names in a source and target protection domain
have been resolved, they can be combined
to create an aggregate domain. And the aggregate
logical protection domain will have entry points,
which is the union of the entry points
that were exported as names from the source and the target or any number of such
domains that have been combined together to create an aggregate domain. So this
combined primitive in SPIN is mainly useful
as a software engineering management tool to combat
the proliferation of many small domains. So,
once again, the road map for creating services
is, write your code as a Modula-3 program with well defined entry points. And
using the SPIN mechanism of create, you
can instantiate a service and export the names
that are available in that service. And
if another logical protection domain wants to use
the names that are exported, it can do so by using the SPIN mechanism resolve
that causes the dynamic binding of the
source and target logical protection domains. And
finally, the combined primitive allows aggregation of
logical protection domains to create an aggregate domain,
that's the union of all the entry points that are available in the component
logical protection domains. This is it. This is the secret sauce in SPIN to get
protection and performance while allowing flexibility.
Everything hinges on the strongly-typed nature
of the programming language that is being used for implementing the operating
system. That is, the language allows compile time checking, and run time
enforcement of the logical protection domains. That's the key to the success of
this approach to providing flexibility, protection,
and performance, all in one bag.